SHANA KNIZHNIK: Hi.
Thank you so much for coming.
And thanks for that
lovely introduction.
IRIN CARMON: Yes.
We also wanted to give a special
shout-out to Google Docs,
without which this collaborative
book would never been written.
SHANA KNIZHNIK: Seriously.
IRIN CARMON: Seriously.
At one point, we were in
two different countries.
That's how you write
a book together
in two different countries, so
thank you to any folks here.
SHANA KNIZHNIK: And
this presentation
is actually on Google Slides.
IRIN CARMON: We didn't
do that just because we
were coming to Google.
We legit our fans, so thank you.
So we want to talk about
how Ruth Bader Ginsburg won
the internet and why it matters.
And I want to start out by
setting a scene for you.
It's June, 2013.
It's the last week of
the Supreme Court term.
As many of you know,
that is the week
that the most important
decisions come down.
On this particular day,
the Voting Rights Act
is on the chopping block.
As you may know, this is one
of the most important pieces
of civil rights legislation.
Chief Justice John
Roberts has the opinion.
And he says, "Any racial
discrimination in voting
is too much, but our country has
changed in the last 50 years."
We have a comic in the book that
depicts this argument as, "LOL,
racism is over."
Now, something that's
customary in the court
bringing its opinions is that
the Chief Justice will say,
Justice Blank has the opinion.
And that opinion will be
read by the justice who
wrote the opinion, in this
case, the Chief Justice himself.
The impact of this decision was
to gut an important provision
of this piece of civil
rights legislation
that made it-- this piece of
legislation, which is referred
to as pre-clearance
forced states
with discriminatory
histories to bring
their laws, the changes
in their voting laws,
to the federal
government ahead of time
so that the federal government
could monitor whether these
would have a
discriminatory impact,
especially on historically
oppressed groups.
So by undermining this
piece of legislation,
by saying that it
was no longer needed
on a very questionable
legal grounding,
essentially it was
opening the door
and has subsequently
opened the door
for more racial
discrimination in voting.
SHANA KNIZHNIK: So in this case,
Justice Ginsburg has a dissent.
And like Irin mentioned, it's
customary for the majority
opinion to be read
from the bench.
But what's more unusual
is for a dissent
to be read from the bench.
And in this case,
Justice Ginsburg
decided to read her
dissent out loud.
And not only that,
she had actually
done so twice before
in the same week,
once in a case regarding
affirmative action,
and once in a combined
two cases involving
workplace discrimination.
Now this is unusual,
and she actually
broke Supreme Court records
with the number of oral dissents
that she gave that week.
And in this case, when you read
the dissent from the bench,
it means something.
It has an import.
It sends a message.
And that message is
that something is wrong.
It's sounding the alarm.
It's like, as the "New York
Times" actually put it,
it's like embarrassing
your spouse at a dinner
party in front of the guests.
So in this case, I was in my
second year of law school.
I was going into my
second year at that time.
And as a future
public defender, I
was appalled at the gutting
of this central tool
for racial justice advocates.
So everyone I knew was
sort of angry about what
was happening on the court.
But the light amidst this anger
was Justice Ginsburg's words.
IRIN CARMON: This
is a court sketch
that was that drawn
live, which we actually
include in the book.
And if you look around
Justice Ginsburg's neck,
a funny thing
about-- a light thing
that we include in the book
is that a lot of people
recognize these neck collars,
the jabots or necklaces
that she wears with
her judicial robes.
Many people don't know
that she chooses them
based on what her
opinion is that day.
So this is her dissent jabot.
So if she comes out
to the bench wearing
this spiky, aggressive,
sparkly, dissenting collar,
it's bad news for liberals
because she's about to dissent.
SHANA KNIZHNIK: And her
words, in this case one
of the most famous lines,
was actually the first post
on the Notorious RBG Tumblr.
"Throwing out pre-clearance when
it has worked and is continuing
to work to stop
discriminatory changes
is like throwing away your
umbrella in a rainstorm
because you're not getting wet."
IRIN CARMON: And we think that
Justice Ginsburg's clear words,
which speak to be people
who are not just attorneys,
and are fierce and
reasoned at the same time,
are part of the
reason why she has
drawn so many people to her.
This is such an
elegant analogy that
uses absolutely no legal jargon
to draw people's attention
to what was a major upending
of a core civil rights law.
SHANA KNIZHNIK: And so
when this case came out,
I was inspired by
Justice Ginsburg's words.
And at the same time, I
had already taken con law
as a 1L, constitutional law.
I knew about Justice
Ginsburg's work
as an advocate at the Women's
Rights Project at the ACLU.
And I knew something about
her story, her life story.
And I realized there was no
space on the internet that
was just dedicated to
celebrating this amazing figure
in our history.
And so I figured, what
better way to celebrate her
than to juxtapose her with
a larger than life figure
in our history as well, the
late, great Notorious B.I.G.
So I started a Tumblr
and I designed a t-shirt.
And this is-- as
you can see, this
was the Notorious RBG t-shirt.
And let's just say
that it took off.
IRIN CARMON: Yeah,
to say the least.
Here's an iconic image of
Biggie Smalls that has found
its way onto our book cover.
And in the center are some--
those posters and stickers
blanketed Washington, DC
on the same week that we're
talking about, June, 2013,
the week of the Shelby County
decision and the other oral
dissents that we mentioned
that also concerned civil rights
and remedies to discrimination.
And the middle image is "Can't
Spell Truth Without Ruth"
and it's a Basquiat crown,
so definitely taking
this kind of vernacular
of the hip-hop movement.
And that's a little plug for our
t-shirts, the Notorious R.B.G.
t-shirt.
That's my little brother.
Nail art-- there is Ruth
Bader Ginsburg nail art.
SHANA KNIZHNIK:
There's also art art.
IRIN CARMON: This illustration's
in the Times today, by the way.
We were all very excited.
That one is called "Ruth
Bader Ginsburg-- Smiting
Her Enemies," which, as I
tried to explain in my op-ed
in the "New York Times" this
weekend, she would never do.
She would just very gently
argue with her enemies.
But she would smite them
with the force of her reason.
SHANA KNIZHNIK: Right.
She likes to say that the
way that you take down
your adversaries is by painting
their arguments in the best
light possible and then--
IRIN CARMON: Knocking them down.
SHANA KNIZHNIK: Yeah.
So there was also
embroidery and needlepoint.
IRIN CARMON: Legos.
SHANA KNIZHNIK: We
actually got a chance
to meet the R.B.G. Lego
and her creator yesterday.
IRIN CARMON: Yes.
Just like Justice Ginsburg
herself, small but powerful.
SHANA KNIZHNIK:
And as mentioned,
lots of Halloween costumes.
We're thinking about
doing a contest this year.
IRIN CARMON: Yes.
Keep in mind when you're
choosing your Halloween
costumes.
Tag us, Notorious R.B.G.
SHANA KNIZHNIK: And of course--
IRIN CARMON: Weekend Update.
You got Ginsburned.
Kate McKinnon, the
brilliant tattoos.
SHANA KNIZHNIK: Several tattoos.
But Justice Ginsburg
is still, after all,
an 82-year-old
Jewish grandmother.
This was her reaction to
seeing tattoos on her face.
IRIN CARMON: She said-- this is
in my interview with her-- she
said, why would you
do that to yourself?
It's permanent.
And actually, another
occasion in which I saw her,
she had just read the book.
And she said, you know, there's
something I have to tell you.
And I was so worried.
She has famously high standards.
And she said, listen.
No one should ever
get a tattoo of me.
This has gone too far.
SHANA KNIZHNIK: So why is it
that people of our generation
have become so excited
about Ruth Bader Ginsburg,
almost obsessive?
Was it just a passing meme,
like Menswear Dog or LOLcats?
IRIN CARMON: I
love Menswear Dog.
But I think that this is
something-- there's something
more going on here
than just fun memes.
I think specifically, what
Justice Ginsburg has devoted
her life to, and
what she represents,
at a moment in which
important civil rights
laws and the
women's rights gains
that she had devoted her career
to are on the chopping block.
At a point in which
there are still
too few women in positions
of authority and power,
she is a woman who has devoted
her entire career to bringing
along other women
and other people who
are historically disadvantaged.
She has done so with
intellectual integrity,
with grace.
And as we learned from
writing this book,
she knows of which she speaks.
The causes she's devoted her
life to have also inflected
her own life.
SHANA KNIZHNIK: So obviously,
Ruth Bader Ginsburg
is more than just a
hilarious Jewish bubbe
who talks about getting
drunk on California
wine before the State
of the Union address.
That was the reason she
gave for why she fell asleep
at the State of the Union.
But we also know that in
fact, she was up all night
working before.
She's a famous night owl.
So she often gets about
two hours of sleep,
even to this day.
And we have so much
to learn from her.
And we're so in debt to her.
So we wanted to bring
what we learned about her
in writing this book to
you guys and to everyone
who able to read it.
First of all, her life story
is absolutely fascinating.
She's gone through so much.
Actually, her sister died
when she was six years old,
so she ended up being an
only child after that.
And her mother
passed away the day
before her high
school graduation--
IRIN CARMON: --where she
was scheduled to speak.
SHANA KNIZHNIK: And she
ended up not attending
as a result. In law school,
she went to Harvard Law
with her husband, who
was a year above her.
She had a one-year-old
child when she started.
And in addition to all
of that, her husband
actually got cancer while
they were in law school.
IRIN CARMON: I think we have
a photo of them together.
SHANA KNIZHNIK: Yep.
And she actually would
type his papers for him
and take his notes that
were taken by his classmates
after doing all of her work,
after taking care of him,
of her, of her child Jane.
So we really couldn't-- we took
inspiration in her work ethic
when we were doing
this book, for sure.
IRIN CARMON: Cancer has been
something that has inflected
Justice Ginsburg's life.
As you may know, she herself
has had cancer twice.
And yet with the
same kind of stamina
that she showed while she was a
law student and caring for both
her cancer-stricken
husband and her daughter,
her young daughter
at the time, she
has never missed a
day on the bench.
SHANA KNIZHNIK: That
actually includes the day
after her husband of
nearly 60 years passed away
from cancer in 2010.
IRIN CARMON: Even while
she was at law school,
just down the road
from here, she--
I think getting
to law school was
the point in which this very
studious, quiet young woman
hoped that she could
finally be seen
as an intellectual person
who had contributions
to offer, and not
just as a girl who
would get married, get pregnant,
and leave the workforce.
SHANA KNIZHNIK: And she
did make law review.
She was one of two women
to make law review here.
You can see her on
the right there.
They separated the two
women in this picture
and said that they were the
two roses amidst the thorns.
IRIN CARMON: But even
at Harvard Law School,
where she had a chance to pursue
her interests and her dreams,
the first week of
law school, the dean
summoned all of the
women to a dinner.
There were nine of
them in the class.
And they all sat
around in a circle.
And she was sitting
next to a professor who
had written a fundamental
textbook, who she described
as looking like a god to me.
She couldn't have been more
thrilled to be at this dinner,
and more nervous.
And the dean, Erwin
Griswold, who gave himself
a lot of credit for having
brought women to the Harvard
Law School, looks around and
said, "Now, ladies, each of
you have to tell me,
how can you justify
taking the place of a man?"
And Justice Ginsburg was so
flummoxed that she stood up.
She had an ashtray.
She was a chain
smoker at the time.
She had an ashtray on
her lap and the ashes
scattered everywhere.
And when she stood up
to answer, she said,
"I thought it would
be good to know
what it is my husband does."
SHANA KNIZHNIK: Erwin
Griswold would later
say that that question was
not meant to be serious,
that he was actually just trying
to prepare the women for what
they would face
in the workforce,
or that he was just kidding.
We don't know about that.
IRIN CARMON: There
was another woman
who answered the
question by saying,
what better place
to catch a man?
But that was not actually what
Justice Ginsburg was there
to do.
And what's so interesting about
her life is that had she not
experienced the kind of
discrimination that she did,
she might have gone along
the path of just becoming
a very good lawyer, of just
becoming a civil procedure
professor.
But in fact, because of the ways
that she was denied the chance
to fulfill her
potential, it put her
on the path of
fighting for justice.
On the left is a photo
of Justice Ginsburg
and her husband when
they were stationed
at a military base in Oklahoma.
That's when, about a year
after they got married,
she got pregnant and was
working in the civil service
while her was in the
military, before law school.
And she placed within a certain
ranking as a civil servant,
but then they found
out she was pregnant.
And they told her,
but you can't travel.
She was only three
months pregnant.
So they demoted her.
And when her pregnancy
became more advanced,
they made it very clear that
it was time for her to go.
She would later go on to
bring important cases in which
service members and other women
were fired from their jobs,
told that they had to
get an abortion or quit,
or just placed on what they
called maternity leave, which
was unpaid, basically, getting
kicked out of your job.
But it would be a while until
she would get to that point.
On the right is a
photo of her while she
was a professor at Rutgers.
10 years later, she
became pregnant again
in a happy accident, and
still, not having tenure,
was afraid to tell her
superiors, lest she be fired.
That's when she went to
her mother-in-law's closet
and wore baggy clothing.
This was a job, by the way,
in which she had already
been told, well, we
couldn't possibly
pay you as much as Mr.
X, because your husband
makes a good living.
She would later bring
a sex discrimination
case, class action lawsuit,
with the other women of Rutgers.
And they won.
SHANA KNIZHNIK: And even
before she was a professor--
she graduated at the top of
her class at Columbia Law,
where she was forced to transfer
because Harvard Law wouldn't
give her a degree
if she completed
her third year at Columbia.
So she graduated from Columbia
at the top of her class.
She was at the top of
our class at Harvard Law,
on both law reviews.
And yet still, she was unable
to get a job at any law firm.
And actually, a professor
of hers at Columbia
had to bribe, basically, a
district court judge in New
York to take her on as a clerk.
He said, if you don't take
on Mrs. Ruth Ginsburg,
I will never send you
another Columbia clerk again.
That was the stick.
The carrot was that
if he didn't like her,
the professor would be able
to send a replacement Columbia
clerk.
IRIN CARMON: A man.
SHANA KNIZHNIK: A man.
But let's just say
she did all right.
IRIN CARMON: He did not look
for a male backup for that role.
10 years later, in the
'70s, Justice Ginsburg
co-founded the ACLU
Women's Rights Project,
where her experiences with pay
discrimination and pregnancy
discrimination, being
denied jobs just because she
was a woman were
all brought to bear
as she built a series of cases
that successfully convinced
the Supreme Court that women
were equal under the law.
Something didn't happen until
the '70s were well underway,
it was perfectly legal to treat
women as if their contributions
in the economic and political
spheres mattered less.
SHANA KNIZHNIK:
She brought cases
on behalf of men as well as
women, which she received
criticism about, because
it was after all called
the Women's Rights Project.
But she knew that
in order for there
to be true equality and
liberty for all people,
that-- her vision of
feminism was that you needed
to be free to be you and me.
So that meant bringing
cases on behalf
of men who wanted to
shatter stereotypes
by being primary caregivers
for their elderly parents
and for their children.
IRIN CARMON: In
essence, what we've
learned is that Justice
Ginsburg's version of feminism
still has a lot
to teach us today.
This is, by the way, a meme
from the Beyonce voters Tumblr.
We think that one reason that
Justice Ginsburg has struck
a chord among young
people and the reason
that we're excited to tell
people more about her life
is because we still have so much
unfinished business of gender
equality and the principles
for which she fought for,
which was she always said, it's
not just women's liberation.
It's men's and
women's liberation.
It also formed the groundwork
for her support of LGBT rights.
It formed the groundwork of
her support for racial justice.
Those are all very
much struggles
that remain unfinished.
And in fact, many of the
gains that she fought for
are now being rolled back.
So I think people respond to
this sort of righteous passion.
And something that
we really want
to convey through the
book, what we really
want to tell as a story is
how much more there is to her
and how deeply
committed she remains
to the cause of equal
citizenship stature.
SHANA KNIZHNIK: And
I think another point
is that anyone can be
revolutionary in their own way.
And for Justice Ginsburg, that's
always been doing the work.
Getting angry is a waste of
time, as she likes to say.
IRIN CARMON: She wants
you to get to work.
SHANA KNIZHNIK: Exactly.
So after the notorious
R.B.G meme took off,
I actually got a chance to go
to Justice Ginsburg's chambers.
And for a minute, I
didn't know that it
was going to happen
because she actually
had a heart procedure done
just a couple weeks before I
was supposed to go there.
And again, she never
missed a day on the bench.
And we went to her
chambers and I asked her
how she was doing, if she had
a message to send to your fans,
to her followers.
And what she told me was
that I could tell them
that she'd be back doing
pushups within a week.
IRIN CARMON: Anyway,
that's all out of us.
We would love to
take your questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Both of you guys have
met her, or interviewed her.
How has she responded to,
other than tattoos [INAUDIBLE]
internet celebrity that has
been happening around her.
SHANA KNIZHNIK: I think
that she enjoys it.
But she's also not a very
outgoing person in real life,
I think.
As she's gotten older,
she's grown into her role
as a public figure.
But what's interesting
about it is
that most of the people that
know her well that we've
talked to in this process
are very surprised
by her role as this
icon at this point.
And so is she.
She said, to think,
me, an icon at 82.
Because she's sort of
the least likely person
to want that for herself.
And so I think that's
part of the appeal,
is that she is this
unassuming person.
But she means so much
to so many people.
IRIN CARMON: That said, I
think she appreciates it,
because she really wants
to engage as many people as
possible in the project of the
court and the broader issues
that she fought for.
So one thing that we
were surprised to learn
when we were
reporting the book was
that throughout the '80s, when
Justice Ginsburg became a lower
court judge and left
the movement formally,
she was repudiated by the
feminists of the '80s, who
said that her focus on equality
was ill-thought out, because it
didn't account for how men
and women were fundamentally
different.
And this was a-- it was
called difference feminism
at the time.
And the idea was that women
spoke in a different voice
and that we needed to celebrate
the fundamental differences.
And something that Justice
Ginsburg has always resisted
is saying that men and women are
essentially one way or another.
So I think for now for her to
become the hot young feminist,
so to speak, must be--
I don't know this,
but I speculate that it is kind
of a sweet validation for her.
And her clerks also told
us that when she's writing,
and when they're
writing on her behalf,
she always instructs them
to write for the public
and to just think about how to
engage people who are outside
of the courtroom
and whose lives are
going to be affected by this.
So I think she's
amused and flattered.
And ultimately, anything that
engages people more profoundly
with her work I believe
is something she values.
AUDIENCE: I'm one of
the many people who
wake up every morning
praying for the continued
health of Ruth Ginsburg.
I wonder if you could
say a couple of words
about the contrast
between her and Sandra Day
O'Connor, the first woman
on the Supreme Court who
also faced immense
difficulties as a woman
and yet developed
of course a very
different judicial philosophy.
I'm wondering how do you
explain-- how much of this
is due, for example, due to
Ruth Ginsburg's growing up
as a Jew in New York, or other
differences in background.
Why did they, both of them
pioneers in certain ways,
why did they end up with such
different judicial opinions?
SHANA KNIZHNIK: So one
thing-- for example,
when Justice Sotomayor was
appointed to the court,
she got in some trouble.
There was a controversy
about a comment
she made that said that a
wise Latina justice would come
to a different conclusion
than, say, a white male justice
or judge.
And Ruth Bader Ginsburg was
asked about that comment.
And she was quick to defend
Justice Sotomayor, then
Judge Sotomayor.
And she said, well, of course
your life experiences are
very valuable to the
decision-making process.
But that doesn't mean
they're better or worse.
It just means that everything
that you've experienced
goes into the
decision-making process.
And I think for her, she valued
the differences between her
and Sandra Day
O'Connor, because it
showed that women are not
all the same, that women
can have different opinions.
And yet it's important for
women to be in the room.
One of the most
upsetting things for her
was when she was the
only woman on the bench
after Justice O'Connor
retired and was
replaced by Samuel Alito.
IRIN CARMON: I do think it's
really interesting to think
about the differences
between them.
Linda Hirshman, who we're
doing an event with this week,
has a great book out that is
a dual biography of Justice
O'Connor and Justice Ginsburg
that we like and appreciate
also, because it has a chapter
in it called "Notorious RBG."
And Linda argues, I
think, that a lot of it
had to do with
specifically the fact
that Justice O'Connor grew
up as a frontierswoman
in this kind of self-reliant
mythology of the West.
Justice Ginsburg
very much grew up
within a tradition
of American Jews
that was horrified by
McCarthyism, in particular.
While she was a
student at Cornell,
there were teachers
and other members
of the community who
were blacklisted.
So I think that that gave
her a deep appreciation
for civil liberties.
The feminism part came
later, but actually
what first drew her to
the law was the censorship
and oppression that was
happening within the United
States.
And it haunted
her in particular,
because her understanding
of World War
II-- she was born in
1933-- was that it
had been a war against racism.
And then she learned that the
troops had been segregated.
And then she saw McCarthyism.
So I think that shaped her
profoundly, in addition to all
of the gendered
experiences that she
would have as she
grew up and gave her
a real strong appreciation
for civil liberties.
AUDIENCE: What's your
advice for young people,
or any person for
that matter, who
don't work in the legal system,
that could have an impact
or voice when it comes to
upholding things that we don't
want to see go away like
exactly what you were talking
about at the start of the talk?
IRIN CARMON: From where
I'm sitting as a reporter
on-- focusing a
lot on the battle
over reproductive rights,
that is something--
it's not happening in
Massachusetts so much,
but that is something
that Justice Ginsburg has
talked a lot about in
terms of her worry.
And I think honestly,
in places where
it's not such a dire issue,
lending support to places
where is a dire issue if that
is something that you support.
Justice Ginsburg often talks
about how the law is not
the engine of social change.
It's social movements, and
it's people making change
through the legislature
and through movements.
And so I think getting engaged
in that process is probably
something that she
would recommend.
She always says,
fight for the things
you care about, but
do so in a way that
would lead others to join you.
So I think she
wants to see people
move beyond that initial
anger and channel it
towards something productive.
And of course, I would say,
within your own spheres here--
I mean, I saw a lot
of awesome things
at Google Diversity--
of course we
know that women are
still underrepresented
in many of these fields.
And something that she's
really committed her life to
is busting stereotypes.
The opinion, the majority
opinion that she's proud of
is the United States
versus Virginia,
where she wrote the opinion that
forced the Virginia Military
Academy to go co-ed.
And people would say
to her, what woman
would want to go to VMI?
And she said, there are
women who want to go.
All that matters
is that getting in
is not on the basis
of your gender.
So I think she would probably
encourage people to continue
the good work that's being
done, to get more women
and people of color in the STEM
fields, since we are at Google.
AUDIENCE: I was going to ask
something similar about what
does she consider her most proud
case, which you just mentioned,
or what she considers maybe
the most important case she's
worked on, or something similar
about another favorite of hers?
SHANA KNIZHNIK: United
States vs. Virginia
is one of her favorites, because
it allowed her to actually cite
a number of the cases that
she argued before the Supreme
Court.
It was really the culmination
of her own legal strategy
at the ACLU, applying
equal protection
to gender discrimination.
So that was obviously something
that she was really proud of.
Another case that
she always mentions
is the Lilly
Ledbetter case, which
was a case about equal pay.
And in particular, she was
in the dissent in that case.
She wrote the
dissenting opinion.
And she basically called out
Congress and said, fix this.
The court has got it wrong here.
We need you, Congress,
to do something about it.
Luckily at that
time for her, there
was a Democratic Congress
and a Democratic President.
So they actually were able to
pass the Lilly Ledbetter Fair
Pay Act.
And in her chambers,
she has a picture
of the signing of that act.
And to her, beyond the
substance of that case
itself, the fact
that it's about equal
pay and how obviously important
that is in her career,
in her life, it also exhibits
something that she really
cares about, which is the
value of the institutions
and the interplay between
those branches of government,
the Supreme Court actually
speaking to Congress
and Congress responding.
And I think when Irin asked
her in Irin's interview
with her what she thinks
about the current Congress,
she is not so optimistic about
the current Congress's ability
to do that sort of thing,
to get things done.
IRIN CARMON: And I think as a
litigator, her favorite case
is-- I think there were
two favorite cases that I
think are worth talking about.
And one was the case
that she thought
would guarantee the right
to reproductive freedom,
before Roe vs. Wade.
And for her, it's the
case that got away.
So Susan Struck was
in Air Force nurse.
She became pregnant
while on active duty.
At that point, the
rule was, you have
to choose-- you either
have to have an abortion
or you have to leave.
And this was pretty remarkable,
because abortion was still
illegal throughout
the United States.
But the Army was actually
requiring female service
members to have
abortions if they
wanted to stay in their jobs.
So Justice Ginsburg represented
Susan Struck in a brief
to the Supreme Court.
The Supreme Court took the case.
And her argument was that
it violates a woman's
equal protection
under the law to say
that she has to
treat her pregnancy
in a particular way or another.
If she can take
disability leave,
she should be treated
just like a man who
needs disability leave.
And only women are
punished for having sex.
That was sort of the bottom
line of her argument.
And she hoped that by
bringing a case of a woman who
didn't want to have an abortion
just like the male cases
that she brought that were
also about vindicating women's
rights, that she would be able
to lay the groundwork that
would eventually lead
to the full range
of reproductive options.
But Erwin Griswold,
the same dean
who had demanded of her that
she justify her presence,
happened to be the Solicitor
General, the top lawyer,
for the United
States of America,
and went to the
military and said,
you've got to
change this policy,
because I'm going
to lose this case.
Yeah, this guy pops up
again and again in her life.
We also have this very
mansplaining letter
that we quote in the book from
him, where he starts to worry,
roughly 1978, that
white men aren't
going to be able to get into
Harvard Law School anymore.
She assures him that
there will always
be a place for white
men with merit.
So the Struck case
ended up being mooted.
And as a result, in that same
term, Roe v Wade was decided.
So Justice Ginsburg always
bemoans Roe v Wade because she
feels it went too far too fast.
Even though she
liked the outcome,
she thought that something
ground in women's equality
would be better.
And the other case
that she loves,
her favorite client, who she's
stayed in touch with for years,
started with a
letter to the editor.
And it was a man who had
recently lost his wife.
She had died in childbirth,
but the child survived.
And he wanted to be the
primary caregiver for his son.
But he could not get the
same widower benefits
that a widow could get.
And the letter says, I
wonder if Gloria Steinem
knows about this.
This is 1976.
And Gloria Steinem did, in
fact, I think, know about it.
And Justice Ginsburg, then the
head of the ACLU Women's Rights
Project, soon learned about
it and brought his case
all the way up to
the Supreme Court,
arguing that it violated his
rights, his dead wife's rights,
as a breadwinner, and
the rights of the child,
to equal protection
under the law.
And the justices at
the time, all men,
had trouble even
believing that a man would
want to care for their child.
They were like,
is this case real?
Are you serious?
Who is this guy?
But she won.
And she stayed in touch with
Stephen Weisenfeld for years.
And many years later, she
performed his son's wedding.
Great.
Well, thank you guys so much.
SHANA KNIZHNIK: Thank
you so much for coming.
[APPPLAUSE]